les propos minimes iner je vais
désarticulé essentiellement autour de
deux points le premier c'est ce qui est
la nature des transformations et le
second ce sera plutôt la réflexion que
ça amène de notre part en matière de
régulation
ce qui nous a fondamentalement conduit à
écrire cet ouvrage c'est l'intuition qui
avait un phénomène de très forte ampleur
ce qu'on appelle maintenant la
plateforme isation qui d'autre on voit
une face immergée émergé pendant qu'ils
aient en particulier celles qui nous
amène ici avec des représentants de
plateformes de mobilité donc tous ceux
qui ont été très très bien aussi pendant
le confinement en particulier les
livreurs et les chauffeurs mais aussi
une phase très immergée est encore
largement invisibles de la plateforme
isation et en particulier aussi à tout
ce qui va venir est en train de se
mettre en place du côté en particulier
des plateformes plus qualifiés
d'intermédiation plus bitossi may be to
be ceci étant notre notre principal
investigations portaient plutôt sur
fictivement ce phénomène de
transformation liés notamment plateforme
plus vite ou ci est le constat que nous
que nous menons et que nous établissons
est vraiment celui d'une accélération y
compris sur ses plates formes là par
rapport à ce qu'on constate n 16 qui a 5
ans adèle qu'on reste sur un champ
victime ans et 3 voilà on sait qu'on est
autour de 5000 travailleurs du côté des
plateformes bi to see mais qu on est là
dans une accélération de la
transformation là qui est très largement
effectivement expliqué aussi dans les
motivations de votre mission sénatoriale
est donc en gros enfin à l'heure
actuelle la question c'est plus qu'
elles sont les métiers qui pourrait être
brisée mais plutôt quels sont les
métiers qui pourrait ne pas être une
brise et si on peut caricative
caricaturer le propos le deuxième point
c'est évidemment la présence et
l'algorithme
et que tout ça mis ensemble ça nous
amène et ça c'est notre conviction à
interpeller même ce qu'on avait on
entend par les frontières de
l'entreprise indépendamment de ce qui se
passe du côté de plateforme isation ce
qui se joue là c'est une capacité
d'aller au delà de tout ce qu'on pouvait
effectivement envisagée en termes
l'externalisation de recours à la
prestation de services
et quand je parlais de la face immergée
cette face immergée on la voit très très
largement montée du côté de
l'intermédiation en particulier de tous
qui sont des compétences dans digital du
côté d'un certain nombre d'entreprises
donc on est dans une phase où on voit
effectivement que peuvent maintenant
être intermédié par plateforme des
fonctions qui sont les plus
périphériques mais aussi lié au coeur de
métier de l'entreprise
et ça c'est cette phase qui est nouvelle
à laquelle on est confronté et le le
pendant du propos sur l'algorithme c'est
aussi de dire il faut pas considérer que
la question du management alors avec
algorithmique serait ni uniquement
présente évidemment au sein des
plateformes la question du management et
algorithmique elle concerne tout le
monde pas seulement les travers de
plateformes
ça peut aller jusqu'à la gestion des
carrières ou le sait et de fait ça amène
et ça entraîne des réponses qui sont
évidemment bien au-delà de la seule
approche par les plateformes mon
deuxième proposé celui sur la régulation
notre approche que nous menons en commun
et de considérer qu'il ya un vrai un
problème majeur andrée quilibre âge des
relations contractuelles on est face à
des asymétries très forte qui sont
entraînés par six nouvelles formes
d'intermédiation et si nous allons nous
dans notre raisonnement jusqu'à enfin d
appuyer l'idée qu'il faut même osé
c'était très facile pour nous parce
qu'on n'est pas juriste repenser les
frontières entre droit du travail et
droit la concurrence alors heureusement
on prend un pied sur quelques juristes
considèrent comme assez sérieux comme
notamment mario di stefano qui a
coordonné un numéro spécial dans les
eaux européennes économique européenne
la baronne journal excusez moi sur ces
sujets là
et c'est cette question là évidemment
elle appelle aussi des réponses qui sont
inédites
ceci étant si on essaye un petit peu de
s'appuyer sur les cadres de régulation
qui sont à notre disposition
notre approche est de considérer qu'il
ya un enjeu majeur du point de vue de la
capacité à mettre en place des règles de
concurrence équilibré nous sommes
intimement convaincus qu'il ya une
réponse qui peut être apportée du point
de vue de la prise en compte de
régulation sectorielle
c'est pour ça que nous poussons nous
dans nos propositions depuis le départ
pour que le dialogue social s'installe
au niveau sectoriel qui est à ce jour le
seul en capacité d'apporter des règles
de concurrence équilibrée entre les
acteurs mais cette question de la
concurrence équilibrée elle peut aussi
si on pousse quand même un petit peu le
raisonnement plus loin sa pensée aussi
sur la capacité à permettre à des plates
à des fins allée des acteurs en capacité
de bénéficier des effets de réseau et
donc à des plateformes alternatives
d'émerger
ce qui nous amène à des outils qui sont
différents de la régulation sectorielle
le deuxième terrain de régulation il est
évidemment social notre notre constat à
nous et notre approche est de considérer
qu'il faut aussi aussi osé dépasser la
proche de twitter est donc réfléchir
quelque chose qui relève plus d'une
approche sur la statue est de droit de
l'actif et nous avons un certain de
propositions que nous portons ceci étant
ça n'exclut pas de considérer qu'on est
bien dans certains cas dans des comptes
dans des situations de dépendance avérée
comme notamment le rappeler très
justement le rapport fin et notre notre
principale arme on va dire en termes de
régulation que nous proposons nous c'est
celle du dialogue social et de tout ce
qui permettra de mettre en oeuvre un
dialogue social équilibré en particulier
sur les avec l'émergence des
représentants légitimes
une brique à laquelle matthias alors
j'aimerais contribuer dans les derniers
mois mais pas mais par ailleurs on est
parfaitement conscient aussi et ça je
pense que certain nombre
d'interlocuteurs ici le souci que ça ne
peut pas tout
un certain nombre de régulation
impérative à sont nécessaires et qu'en
particulier il ya tout un champ de
réflexion à mener aussi du côté de la
responsabilité employeur donc on y
reviendra matière de santé sécurité au
travail mais aussi en matière de
responsabilités de donneur d'ordre sous
traitant
ce qui fait aussi l'objet d'une
proposition de loi par un sénateur qui
je crois est présent dans cette salle
j'en ai terminé pour mon propos merci
écoutez avait sept minutes sont passées
ça passe excessivement vite donc je vous
prendrai la parole lors des échanges
bien entendu pardon je n'avais pas mis
je vous m'entendez bien là je remercie
la présence de notre collègue jack un
qui est l'auteur de la proposition de
loi
et puis j'ai indiqué qu'on avait passé
les sept minutes de la première
intervention dont vous pourrez partir et
pour la suite je vais passer la parole
maintenant on représentants de l'über
france donc madame charpentier jean
massy mais j'ai préféré ce que je vous
propose pour vous remercie tout d'abord
nous permettre d'intervenir avec lauren
guardiola devant vous aujourd'hui je
vous propose d'articuler mon propos
liminaire autour de trois axes très
brièvement rappelé qu' über et même si
tout le monde a sa petite idée sur la
question mais surtout pour vous
présenter aussi les différents profils
des travailleurs qui utilisent nos deux
applications humeur et hubert ritz
deuxièmement de vous partager les
constats qu'on a pu faire de l'impact de
la crise sanitaire sur ces travailleurs
et nos activités
et troisièmement de conclure et d'ouvrir
sur la vision qui est la nôtre notamment
à l'aune de leurs ordonnances sur le
dialogue social qui va nous permettre
d'arriver un vrai véritable dialogue
social sectoriel sur sur ce sujet sur
humeur très rapidement et
malheureusement il faut souvent continue
à la raclée hubert est une entreprise de
technologie et bien évidemment est une
implication permanente deux applications
d'intermédiation uniquement nous sommes
implantés en france depuis maintenant un
peu plus de
dix années et la france était le premier
pays dans le caliber s'est implanté
après les états unis au départ über
c'était uniquement de l'intermédiation
dans le monde des vtc donc la mise en
relation entre des chauffeurs désormais
professionnels et des passagers et
depuis 2016 nous avons également une
activité de livraison à domicile et vous
avez c'est important de le noter des
profils parmi ces travailleurs
extrêmement différents chauffeur vtc une
profession extrêmement réglementée et
donc souvent des chauffeurs qui exerce
cette activité à temps plein avec des
examens et donc des coûts en termes
d'investissements à l'entrée qui sont
relativement élevée et d'autre part les
livreurs qui pourront enfin la livraison
à domicile a vocation à être une
livraison à être une activité partielle
par nature pourquoi parce qu'elle est
non seulement saisonnière mais également
pendulaires et donc de fait on a des
profils de travailleurs très différents
beaucoup d'étudiants beaucoup de
salariés qui utilisent cette activité
comme un moyen de parvenir à des revenus
accessoires et bien évidemment des
travailleurs beaucoup plus jeune avec
une moyenne d'âge de 25 ans sur les
constats que nous avons pu tirer au
cours de la crise sanitaire allons ne
sont pas forcément les seuls à les faire
mais peut-être autour de deux points
les constats sur vraiment le travail des
plateformes et des constats plus
largement sur l'étrave le travail
indépendant sur le travail de
plateformes je pense principalement à
l'essor de la livraison vous avez
mentionné monsieur le président est là
dessus selon ton j'aperçois c'est qu'au
cours de la crise sanitaire
ce mode de travail du fait de la
flexibilité qu'ils offrent et des très
faibles barrières à l'entrée a permis à
un certain nombre de personnes d'accéder
à des revenus non négligeables et
surtout à certaines personnes qui
n'avaient accès à aucune autre source
potentielle de revenus voire même
n'était pas éligible aux aides
gouvernementales
dans cette période mais parfois même au
delà de cette période est donc ça a été
véritablement une opportunité pour ces
travailleurs qui ont pu générer des
revenus et ceux dont on s'aperçoit en
interrogeant les livreurs c'est que
malgré le contexte sanitaire compliqué
78% d'entre nous ont indiqué être
satisfait de leur expérience pendant
pendant une partie de la crise et cela
ressort d'une constitution annuel que
nous avons réalisée auprès d'eux sur le
travail des indépendants
plus largement ce dont on s'aperçoit
c'est que bien évidemment on est
toujours face à un déficit de protection
sociale pour ces travailleurs est donc
ce que über a mis en place pendant la
crise pour les accompagner et non sans
prendre des risques juridiques sur sur
ces points c'est que nous avons fourni
des équipements de protection
individuelle gratuitement ou bien
rembourser le coût de ces équipements et
nous avons également mis en place une
compensation financière pour les
travailleurs en cas de diagnostic
positif au co vide ou de confinement
imposés 22 quarantaine imposée et bien
évidemment cela venait en complément des
aides gouvernementales et du fonds de
solidarité dont beaucoup de travailleurs
utilisant vos applications ont également
pu bénéficier
et ce qui nous semble être le constat
est la conclusion nous faisons c'est que
finalement cette crise elle doit
accélérer la mise en place des nouvelles
mesures en matière de protection sociale
pour les indépendants d'une part avec
une premier prieur très importante à
l'édifice qui a été fait par l'
ordonnance sur le dialogue social et ça
c'est particulièrement important parce
que ça va permettre à horizon 2020 3
d'avoir de véritables accords sectoriels
qui vont permettre d'avoir des minima
sociaux d'une certaine manière sur des
sujets aussi variés que les revenus la
formation professionnelle après la
prévention des risques professionnels et
d'autre part sur la protection sociale
que vous savez que la protection sociale
va faire l'objet de textes différents
puisque les représentants des
travailleurs des plateformes ont fait
part à monsieur bruno mettling dans le
cadre de sa mission du fait qu'il
voulait véritablement avoir quelque
chose
un texte différent or dialogue social et
j'en terminerai très rapidement sur la
vision qui est la nôtre
la vision que nous portons et que nous
avons toujours portée c'est
véritablement de pouvoir concilier
indépendance et flexibilité et meilleure
protection sociale via notamment le
dialogue social indépendance et
flexibilité pourquoi parce qu'ils nous
le disent et ils nous le répètent les
chauffeurs font ce métier à 89% pour
être leur propre patron et les
indépendants le disent également dans un
sondage au doxa de février 2021
85% des indépendants choisissent
délibérément ce statut pour être et
exercer leurs activités de manière
indépendante et donc on considère que
les premiers travaux qui ont été faits
sur la protection sociale la loi elcom
riz ou la loi des mobilités sont certes
des avancées mais ne sont pas encore
suffisants pour assurer une protection
sociale équivalente et je n'entrerai pas
dans les détails mais vous avez dans ce
sondage au doxa d'importants chiffres
qui permettent de mettre en exergue les
disparités entre salariés et est
indépendant à revenus équivalents et
dans tous les cas j'aimerais conclure
sur un point c'est que adressé le
dialogue social a dressé la protection
sociale il faut ajouter à cela une
nécessaire et meilleure prévisibilité
juridique vous l'avez dit aujourd'hui on
a des décisions de justice qui parfois
de même juridiction sur des versions
d'applications identique parts dans les
sens complètement opposées et c'est pour
ça qu'il nous paraît extrêmement
important de pouvoir à tout le moins
clarifier les frontières entre
indépendants et salariés et nous avons
des exemples à travers par exemple une
décision de la cour européenne sur
une plateforme you d'elle je vais passer
la parole au ministre hervé novelli qui
intervient ce matin en tant que
président de l'association des
plateformes d'indépendants et je lui
laisse la parole
localement le clan merci monsieur le
merci monsieur le président et je vous
renvoie votre salut contre tours en jour
qu'elle vous avez fait allusion tout à
l'heure avec plaisir alors je voudrais
bien sûr décrire en quelques mots ce
qu'est l'association des plateformes
d'indépendants qui s'est créée en
novembre 2019 donc une jeune association
qui aujourd'hui si l'on intègre les deux
associations professionnelles qui nous
ont rejoints dans le partenaire dans un
partenariat c'est à dire la fédération
des auto écoles en ligne et la
fédération des transports publics qui
travaille donc dans la branche des vtc
et bien c'est aujourd'hui plus de 30
plateformes qui sont adhérentes à notre
association dont donc beurre bien sûr
mais beaucoup d'autres des grandes des
moyennes et des petites et pourquoi je
prends ce tampon pour dire cela c'est
pour exprimer l'ampleur du phénomène sur
lequel chacun s'est exprimé avant moi
mais qui métier est important madame
chami a parlé de plateforme isation elle
a parfaitement raison c'est ma
conviction était que on est au début de
cette plateforme isation de l'économie
et qu' il faut bien sûr veiller à cela
pourra poser un cadre de régulation qui
convienne à tous doit d'abord faire une
observation liminaire ont donné
l'ampleur du phénomène du rebond du
travail indépendant dans d'autres pays
il est très important de le noter ça
n'est pas marginal et est donc le
travail à indépendant qui semblait se
réduire peu à peu devant le fait
salariale depuis dix ans connaît que dix
ans un spectaculaire rebond
en france bien sûr mais mais mais
partout ailleurs et c'est
essentiellement lié à ce qu'on appelle
la révolution numérique et la capacité
que cette révolution à devoir mettre en
face d'une demande précise une offre
précise beaucoup plus facilement par le
biais des applications
un chiffre qu'il faut avoir en tête
aujourd'hui on estime que le nombre des
indépendants tous confondus tuerait j'ai
écouté le président babarit à nous
donner ces chiffres dont une d'une
précédente audition dont on peut estimer
qu'il ya entre 3 millions et nier et 4
millions de dhs indépendant au sens
large et non recouvrant toutes les
formes de travail indépendant
commerçants artisans professions
libérales micro-entrepreneurs le nouveau
nom de l'auto entrepreneur est
aujourd'hui sur ces trois millions et
demi
et bien il y en a plus de la moitié qui
aujourd'hui sont représentés par ce
qu'on appelle les micro-entrepreneurs le
nouveau nom de ces auto entrepreneurs
c'est dire que les choses évoluent et
c'est aussi dire combien on a besoin de
s'intéresser à cela et on ne réduira pas
ce phénomène a quelque chose de prénoms
marginal ma conviction est que ce rebond
entre guillemets du travail indépendant
est et durable et va connaître un essor
non pas du fait de la volonté des champs
mais il est tout simplement du fait de
la révolution technologique
alors la création de l' aquila puis
aujourd'hui est représenté dans les
trois secteurs qui structurent ce monde
des plateformes le secteur bien sûr de
la mobilité avec les livraisons et les
pc mais aussi les plateformes dites de
services à la personne et les
plateformes dites de services aux
entreprises dont on a parlé tout à
l'heure
l'api s'est créé autour du
j insiste parce que il faut se défier de
telle ou telle caricature qui est
facilement le véhicule et la charte de
l'apic contient les sa fondation en
novembre 2019 donc bien avant la mission
froid la mission mettling un certain
nombre de deux directions notamment
l'amélioration de la protection sociale
ou des travailleurs passant par les
plateformes pour trouver des clients
l'amélioration de leur formation la
nécessité de les doter d'un revenu
suffisamment attractifs mais aussi la
nécessité et j'en viens au coeur de la
problématique qui n'ont réuni la
nécessité de les doter d'un cadre
juridique sécurisé mais est pour nous là
les choses sont claires il ya d'un côté
les salariés dont on a parlé tout à
l'heure avec le lien de subordination
qui les caractérise encore que ce lien
de subordination évolue lui aussi
notamment on a pu le constater à la
faveur d'un bon débit et du
développement du télétravail mais aussi
au delà de 7 2 7 de ce développement il
y a bien sûr beaucoup d'autres beaucoup
d'autres facteurs trois points
maintenant pour terminer pour ne pas
abuser sur la mission froid cette
mission n'a pas satisfait les
plateformes parce qu'elles contenaient
d'abord elle s'est livrée à un
redoutable travail c'est sûr et il faut
le saluer mais mais la solution
préconisée de portage salarial qui n'est
pas utilisé nulle part n'était pas pour
nous quelque chose d'opérationnel quant
à la mission mettling ci a consisté à
proposer une écriture de leur donnant ce
dont on a parlé
eh bien aujourd'hui c'est en donnant l
elle suscite beaucoup d'attentes étaient
surtout elle laisse de côté la
représentation des plateformes
elle même l'autorité de régulation qui a
été créée par cette ordonnance n'est
bien il reste un an à ce qu'elle se
mette à fonctionner et là nous sommes
attentifs aux coûts qui sera supportée
par les plateformes puisqu'une autre
taxe a été créée par cette ordonnance
enfin sera créée dans le cadre d'une loi
de finances à à venir et donc tout ça
sont des points d'inquiétude sur le
salon je salue en tant que président de
la peep le fait que le sénat dans sa
grande sagesse se saisissent de cela
pour apporter une vie et mais je conclus
la régulation dont ce secteur a besoin
mais n'a surtout pas besoin de
contrainte excessive qui devrait à la
fois au développement de cet écosystème
fragile et aussi aux indépendants qui
aujourd'hui rejoignent ces plates sont
pour
pour en vendre des kits une clientèle
amélioré je donne ma parole d'un homme
blanc de la si vous voulez et merci pour
cette question madame là à porter alors
en effet sur les questions de protection
sociale au beurre et le secteur ont été
actifs depuis depuis 2016 puisque avant
même la mise en oeuvre de la loi elle
comme riz oeufs beurre avait passé un
partenariat avec l'assureur axa pour
donner des droits en matière de
protection contre les accidents du
travail et les maladies professionnelles
à ses travailleurs et la loi elle comme
riz est venu en fait renforcer cette
initiative par une obligation les
plateformes ont désormais l'obligation
de proposer une protection dit à tmp ou
de rembourser les frais à tmp de ces de
ces travailleurs donc c'est entièrement
à la charge des plateformes humber est
venu compléter on pourrait parler de
l'initiative un peu supra légale puisque
en dehors des courses qui sont réalisés
avec le beurre les chauffeurs et
les livreurs sont également protégés
contre ces risques et nous avons
également ajouté une prime de
parentalité pour les chauffeurs et les
livreurs
à cela s'ajoutent également des éléments
de formation parce que vous l'avez dit
c'est extrêmement important
nous proposons des contenus de formation
des contenus de certification de
compétences mais aussi d accompagnement
dans les projets de reconversion
à titre d'exemple 40% des livreurs
disait en 2020 qu'ils avaient un projet
professionnel autres mais qu'ils avaient
besoin d'accompagnement pour définir
concrétiser ce projet est donc nous
avons fait des partenariats avec des des
tierces parties pour leur apporter ce
soutien sur la question en effet du
financement du cpf c'est évidemment très
important et la loi d'orientation des
mobilités est venu légiférer en
obligeant les plateformes à financer le
cpf des travailleurs les décrets de mise
en oeuvre sont en cours de publication
et je pense que sur votre questions
liées aux accords oui nous l'espérons le
dialogue sectoriel qui sera mis en place
dans les mois à venir doit permettre de
trouver des accords avec les
travailleurs avec les représentants
légitimes de ces travailleurs sur les
questions de prévention sur les
questions de santé au travail
c'était d'ailleurs une des conclusions
du rapport de la task force dont
monsieur dufour faisait faisait partie
mais comme nous l'avons dit en
introduction les représentants de ces
travailleurs ont souhaité que la
question de la protection sociale ne
soit pas à la main du dialogue social
est ce que nous comprenons très bien et
donc maintenant il nous faut trouver un
vecteur il nous faut trouver la proche
sur cette question du renforcement de la
protection sociale pour ces travailleurs
dans les mois à venir et à ce titre
on pourrait imaginer que le plan
indépendant préparé par le ministre
grisé et dont monsieur le président
faisait allusion dans son introduction
pourrait être un vecteur intéressant
pour contenir d un renforcement de cette
protection sociale et puis je finirai
par la question de la portabilité des
données personnelles en effet c'est un
c'est une question extrêmement
importante
sachez que la l'homme prévoit que les
travailleurs peuvent demander à tout
moment autre plateforme
une production de toutes les données
personnelles que nous avons pu avoir sur
ce travailleur équipes qui forment une
sorte de cv qui est transférable
partageable avec une tierce partie pour
le travailleur par exemple un employeur
potentiel
merci merci
markine liberté de cette question donc
bonne bonne journée avec le ministre
je me tourne vers un fabien gay est ce
qu'il est en ligne fait bien sûr bonjour
fernandez oui je te donne la parole
bonjour martinez et michel merci
beaucoup à nos intervenantes et
intervenants
alors j'ai bien entendu le président
camille pas de discours je sais que
c'est pour moi donc je vais faire très
court on a auditionné monsieur froid
lundi
c'était très intéressant et il a été
assez honnête j'aurais bien il a dit
j'ai fait ça j'ai fait ce rapport dans
un moment de complexe y compris parce
que il ya des juridictions qui sont
intervenus il ya eu des arrêts
d'ailleurs que quelques intervenants ni
un peu d'ailleurs la loi est dit par
exemple elle a reconnu la contestation
que ces travailleurs et travailleuses
n'étaient pas des indépendants voyez pas
ce qu'il faut contacter des choses elle
requalifier un certain nombre de choses
et pas qu'en france en contrat de
travail
donc il faut pas commis quand même ce
qui vit ce qui vient de se produire et
qui va continuer à ce problème mais il
l'a reconnu lui même c'est pas
satisfaisant pour ses travailleurs et
ses travailleuses qui veulent plus de
protection sociale et une autre réunion
ratio une meilleure rémunération et puis
pas satisfaisant pour les plateformes de
travail qui elles veulent sauvegarder
business est un modèle économique est
d'ailleurs la question opposants c'est
comment sauvegarder ce modèle économique
et que on offre à ses salariés une
meilleure protection sociale et un
salaire c'est ça la question
d'ailleurs moi je crois quand même je
vous le dis que quand on business
économique business model je pense qu'il
ya une petite question tourne
l'imposition quand même ce que nous
sommes des législateurs est une grande
multinationale une transnationale comme
du beurre il ya quand même un petit
question d'impôt qu'elles payent peu ou
pas c'est mieux c'est moins deux
millions de par an grâce à une
optimisation fiscale en passant par des
paradis fiscaux que son pays bas les de
labouheyre et et d'autre les derniers
bons dont moi j'ai une question
voyez je fais pas loin je crois qu'on
est le détournement des mots pour go
pour en réalité sauvegarder ce business
économie de ces grandes transnationales
par exemple ce ne sont pas des
indépendants mais des autonomes
d'ailleurs monsieur froid le dit ils ne
choisissent pas eux mêmes le statut
d'auto entrepreneur si ils veulent
travailler avec une plate forme je je je
situe beurre parce qu'ils sont
aujourd'hui mais ce n'est pas à eux
entendent telle qu'on s'entende bien
s'ils veulent travailler avec über ils
sont obligés de prendre le statut
d'auto-entrepreneur statut
d'auto-entrepreneur d'ailleurs qui est
un peu détournée on ne parle d'ailleurs
plus deux emplois on parle d'activité et
on ne parle plus salaire on parle de
revenus pourtant si on considère que les
indépendants
pourquoi nous moi je dis par exemple que
ce sont des salariés parce que si on est
indépendant et c'est sur ça que je
voudrais vous entendre on doit choisir
sa clientèle
on doit choisir le prix qu'on
on fait bon et exécuter sa tâche et on
doit choisir aussi en réalité quand on
veut travailler etc
mais surtout pourquoi vous êtes une
plate forme de travail c'est qu'il ya un
lien de subordination pour deux choses
la première c'est que vous pouvez
connecté ou déconnecté
quand vous le souhaitez ces travailleurs
et les travailleuses notamment à travers
la notation et puis à la question
algorithmique et s'ils se sont tellement
des indépendants il devrait pouvoir
avoir accès à cet algorithme qui n'est
pas un ordinateur mais qui est bien fait
par des hommes et par les femmes qui
détiennent le pouvoir et qui sont
aujourd'hui ces grandes plateformes
donc voila j'aimerais vous entendre sur
cette question parce que il ya un
détournement des mots entre indépendance
et autonomie et moi je pense que ses
travailleurs et ses travailleuses
ils veulent de l'autonomie mais si vous
voulez être indépendant il faudrait
qu'ils puissent avoir accès à
l'algorithme choisir leurs clients et
choisir le la rémunération à laquelle
ils se payent pour pouvoir effectuer
leurs tâches
ce qui n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui
voilà j'espère avoir été assez pour
monsieur le président merci fabien très
bien et les questions sont très précises
alors je vais demander peut-être hervé
novelli de de réagir sur la description
des indépendants et leurs attentes
et puis ensuite peut-être madame gomez
sur l'aspect juridique qui a été évoqué
enfin évidemment hubert qui pourra
prendre la parole puisque interpellé
par notre collègue tout à l'heure donc
hervé novelli sur ces sujets généraux
oui merci c'est très effectivement là on
vient au coeur du sujet au coeur du
sujet qui est le suivant le droit du
travail contrairement à ce qui parfois
est dit est un droit du travail qui est
salariale je sortais j'ai eu une
discussion il ya deux jours avec une
directrice de la direction générale du
travail qui a employé ce mot c'est vrai
que ces indépendants qui sont intervenus
avec la révolution numérique le droit du
travail ne les aborde qu'à travers à une
requalification il y ait un lien de
subordination et on voit bien combien il
manque aujourd'hui dans notre droit
une définition claire et précise de ce
qu'elle indépendant et moi moi je n'ai
rien à dire n'a ni à redire à ce que par
rapport à ce qu'a dit monsieur monsieur
guay il y as besoin de définir
l'indépendant dans sa capacité d'al de
refuser ou pas et vu de tâches de
pouvoir choisir quand ils veulent
travailler ou pas bref ce qui définit un
indépendant et l'indépendant n'est pas
défini aujourd'hui dans le droit et il
est défini que comme un non salariés
susceptibles à terme d'être requalifié
essais on voit bien toute l'empreinte
salariale et c'est bien naturel que
portent les codes du travail nous avons
besoin d'une définition claire et
précise
à la lumière des jurisprudences y
compris de celles de la cour de
cassation en fin de de l'arrêt de la
cour de cassation dont on a parlé
nous avons besoin de pouvoir définir
réellement ce qu'est un indépendant
aujourd'hui au 21ème siècle et aussi
quelles sont les règles qui doivent lui
être appliqués bref on on voit que le
code du travail d'aujourd'hui doit être
complétée
par un code du travail des indépendants
qui l'avait qui reste à écrire mais si
déjà dans le plan de monsieur griset il
y avait cette définition de
l'indépendant on aurait fait un grand
pas et on aurait ainsi tracer une
frontière qui ne sera jamais étanche pas
se leurrer et et il a le droit est là
pour pour requalifier éventuellement
pour sanctionner un faux indépendants
mais la frontière qu'il nous faut
établir aujourd'hui reste à écrire je
l'appelle de mes voeux et la pid notre
association en a fait un élément clé de
ces propositions la création en droit
positif de la définition d'un
indépendant merci maman juste je voulais
juste rajouté oui je venais train léger
monde sur la protection sociale parce
que je ne voudrais pas passer sous
silence
et je rejoins largement ce qui a été dit
par hubert ce n'est pas forcément
étonnant compte tenu qu'ils sont
adhérents à notre association pour les
accidents du travail et les maladies
professionnelles
il est naturel il est légitime que les
plateformes
il est aussi légal aujourd'hui que les
plateformes puissent doter les
travailleurs indépendants qui passe par
l de mécanismes visant à financer les
éventuels accidents du travail maladies
professionnelles ça nous semble tout
naturel comme il nous semble aujourd'hui
naturel à la faveur de l'as de la
pandémie de considérer que en termes de
perte de revenu perte de clientèle ou
totale ou ultra majoritaire que l'état
qui a commencé de le faire mais de
manière très marginale
puis se préoccuper d'un revenu de
substitution en cas de perte d'activité
dont on voit bien qu'ils y aillent
il sera où seraient très utiles et n'a
été prise en compte par le fonds de
solidarité mais de manière très
structurelles aujourd'hui réfléchir un
revenu pour perte d'activité donc pour
le travailleur indépendant me semble
quelque chose à l'ordre du jour merci
madame gomes si vous m'entendez je vous
donne la parole pour développer ce sujet
parce que j'aurais dit que peut-être des
choses
merci beaucoup je peux je pense que ce
que j'ai fait ce que je vais rebondir
sur ce que disait monsieur l'infini en
marraine continuité dans le dans propos
effectivement il faut réfléchir très
rapidement avec danse de situation la
situation commande pour travers des
plateformes qui pour le rappeler sont
parmi les plus précaires les livreurs en
particulier on assiste vraiment à une
hyper paupérisation de cette catégorie
de travailleurs
il ya une urgence sociale et économique
à laquelle il faut répondre
la question c'est effectivement qu'il va
y répondre à ce que c'est à l'état de
financer les conséquences de d'une perte
d'activité d'un accident ou est ce que
c'est
comme c'est le cas en protection sociale
et en sécurité sociale en plus
particulièrement
est-ce que c'est plutôt une contribution
patronale qu'il faudrait imaginer
du coup j'en reviens un petit peu au
fondamentaux entre guillemets sur le
permettez cette expression là le droit
du travail et le droit de la protection
sociale existe parce que enfin ça fait
si longtemps qu'on est d'abord être
dispositif pour protéger la relation
salariale qui sont efficaces et éprouvés
encore une fois pourquoi lcd inventé en
permanence des dispositifs qui vont se
rapprocher sont pourtant avoir la même
efficacité et la même facilité
d'utilisation alors que on peut
justement tout simplement prendre ce qui
existe déjà et aux besoins adapté à la
réalité de la pratique et je reviendrai
du coup à deux points le premier plan
dont sur la protection
essentielle en particulier effectivement
les travers des plateformes comme
d'indépendants leur est imposée il ne
bénéficiait pas des régimes
techniquement les maladies
professionnelles aujourd'hui on est
chose de nature assurantiel c'est un
tiers que si vous avez un accident par
exemple trop de gens mais cassée pendant
cinq mois parce que vous étiez à vélo
vous a fait mille raisons qui est une
voiture qui vous a percuté vous allez
avoir un montant pourront se les
derniers montants que je l'en tête mais
ce ne sont plus ceux là peut-être pour
un tibia c'était entre 1500 et 1600
euros alors que vous avez cinq à six
mois d'arrêt donc cinq à six mois de
d'arrêt et touché 1500 euros c'est pas
une chose que être compensée par le
régime de protection sociale pour la
perte par la capacité de travail durant
ces cinq mois ou ces six mois donc on
n'est vraiment pas sur les mêmes
logiques et je parle même pas là de la
nature philosophique de la contribution
sociale et la nature financière par
ailleurs ce qui est aussi un de sujets
d'importance
mais voilà on pourrait passer ma parce
qu'une heure sur les raisons pour
lesquelles il faudrait revenir sur un
mécanisme de protection sociale et de
sécurité sociale la plus fondamentale
plus basique plutôt que passer sur des
mécanismes assurantiels qui sont très
compliquées par ailleurs à mobiliser
pour les travailleurs et monsieur
novelli disait on à une droit qui est du
travail qui s'est concentrée sur la
qualité de salarié
parce qu'on a dû définir ce que c'était
que salarié pour savoir qui à qui on
allait appliquer justement le droit du
travail et droit de la sécurité sociale
on n'a pas des finitions vraiment
législatif du travailleur indépendant
traînait au royaume uni ce qui est
intéressant c'est que on a une
définition de trades de l'indépendance
et l'entrepreneur entrepreneur c'est
celle ou celui qui finalement est maître
de son destin économique la personne qui
va choisir ses clients de laisser les
conditions de travail de rémunération
ses tarifs et c est donc cette 7è
liberté cette existence propre sur le
marché définit la qualité d'entrepreneur
et effectivement on pourrait s'inspirer
de sa définition la route pour se rendre
compte aussi que les travailleurs des
plateformes de travaux salle de pâtes on
ne travaille que j'ai défini tout à
l'heure ne peuvent pas être des
entrepreneurs et c'est plein
pour laquelle il y a des
requalifications actuellement concernant
les chauffeurs avec des seins en
particulier les juges les juges anglais
se sont basés sur la définition
d'entrepreneurs et se sont dit voilà il
est impossible dans ces conditions que
un chauffeur vtc du beurre en
l'occurrence puisse être considéré comme
un entrepreneur donc pourquoi pas
effectivement réfléchir même si la
doctrine commence de plus en plus alors
à dégager de plus en plus des
définitions
il existe en espagne et villages qu'ils
étaient en 2007 il ya eu une initiative
pour réfléchir un statut du travailleur
indépendant et dans ce statut de
travailleur indépendant d'ailleurs il y
avait une partie spécifique pour les
travailleurs indépendants économiquement
dépendants on a fait une sorte de
compilation tous les droits qu'avaient
les indépendants et on avait même donc à
inventer des dispositions spécifiques
pour les situations les personnes en
situation de dépendance économique pour
autant ça n'a pas empêché d'espagne
d'annoncer yolanda diaz particulier la
mise du travail d'annoncer que en dépit
de cette définition parce que les
travailleurs des plateformes et en
l'occurrence là il s'agissait des
livreurs ne peuvent pas être des
indépendants yolande indienne a proposé
donc a annoncé la création d'une loi
spécifique qui va requalifier d'une
présomption de salariat ce qui est
proposé par de nombreux sénateurs
derrière le semble-t-il dans dans pas de
passer dans leurs sénateurs sans doute
mais bien tout cas une certaine partie
de sénateurs proposent justement des
mécanismes de présomptions ou
d'assimilation de des travers des
plateformes à des salariés parce que
c'est le plus simple
on a appliqué la législation sociale et
puis ensuite s'il faut adapter on se
servira la négociation collective donc
c'est le chemin qui empruntent en
espagne c'est à mon sens ce qui est le
chemin le plus simple le plus évident le
plus sécurisant à la fois pour les
plateformes qui vont savoir exactement
quelle doit appliquer comment
l'appliquer qui pourront démarrer aussi
des négociations dans le cadre de la
négociation collective et c'est aussi
plus simple pour les travailleurs eux
aussi seront ou
où ils en sont et quels sont leurs
droits et je pense que c'est fondamental
et je voulais juste terminée sur une
chose les je pense qu'il faut faire
attention à dévoyer ce que c'est qu'un
travailleur indépendant c'est à dire que
travail
un travailleur indépendant c'est
vraiment décidé de mener une activité
avec tous les risques que ça pour
prendre mais aussi de temps dégagé les
profits éventuels et je pense que à
vouloir faire entrer de force les
travailleurs des plateformes qui
pourrait très bien vouloir être
indépendant et qui de ce fait ne le sont
pas revendique du coup une autonomie
dans le cadre du statut salarial vouloir
les faire entrer de force dans statut
d'indépendant s'est dévoyé qu'est ce que
c'est que le travailleur indépendant et
l'entrepreneuriat merci j'ai deux
annonces la première concerne une
intervention supplémentaire de notre
collègue fabien gay qui voulait une
question subsidiaire
et puis aussi indiqué que hervé novelli
nous nous sommes quittés pour d'autres
obligations
donc je le salue et je donne tout de
suite la parole à fabien gay avant de
continuer notre tour de table merci
beaucoup monsieur le président je vous
indique un second juste puisque je sais
que c'est hubert qui va répondre on
comment offrir une protection sociale si
on recale ifip à ses travailleurs et ses
travailleuses en salariés qui toucheront
donc un salaire avec des cotisations qui
ouvre des droits cotisations salariales
et patronales qui ouvre des droits à la
protection sociale et donc couvre
l'ensemble des risques chômage accidents
du travail auprès etc
sinon on n'offre pas une protection
sociale s'il n'y a pas de salaire et si
on reste dans le revenu
c'est donc que on va vers un système
assurantiel
mais ce n'est pas la même chose et c'est
encore dévoyer les mots
ce ne sera donc pas une protection
sociale mais un régime assurantiel
mais si hubert swets continuer à avoir
des auto entrepreneurs
comment ils pensent pouvoir offrir une
protection sociale sans salaire
voilà je vous remercie 6
peut-être madame charpentier qui a la
première partie de la question et c'est
pas parce qu'une solution semble simple
et évidente que c'est forcément la
meilleure et notamment parce que c'est
simplement continuer à vouloir imposer
le salariat à des indépendants qui nous
dit qu'ils nous disaient qu'ils nous
répètent qu'ils veulent rester
indépendant sur le volet purement
juridique personnes et uber certainement
pas ne nie l'existence de cet arrêt de
la cour de cassation
mais le constat que nous faisons c'est
que malheureusement cet arrêt n'a rien
résolu puisqu'il n'est pas suivie par
les juges du fond et la résistance est
forte puisque la majorité des décisions
qui ont été rendues postérieurement à
cette décision en mars 2020 vont dans le
sens d'un refus de requalifier les
travailleurs en salariat et vous avez
principalement la cour d'appel de lyon
et la cour d'appel de paris qui ont
rendu des arts est extrêmement bien
motivés sachant que ça allait faire
l'objet à nouveau d'un débat devant la
chambre sociale
il faut aussi rappeler est le doyen
huglo l'a parfaitement indiquée dans son
commentaire d'arrêt il a indiqué que
c'était il a reconnu que c'était un
arrêt peut-être bien plus politique que
juridique pourquoi parce qu'à ce jour
comme il y à une simple solution guiner
salariat ou indépendant et qu'il n'y a
pas de voie intermédiaire il sait sont
senti forcé d'aller vers la voie du
salariat pour deux raisons et ils le
disent faire bouger et avancer plus
rapidement le gouvernement sur ces
questions là et envoyer un signal
d'alarmé aussi aux plate formes et nous
l'avons entendu sur le fait que
certaines pratiques devait changer
nous ne sommes pas restés sourds à cet
appel puisque nous avons des réceptions
de là
et continuer à renforcer des travaux
qu'on avait déjà mis en place pour
véritablement améliorer
l'indépendance de ces travailleurs et
pour vous donner des exemples
alors il ya eu un point qui a été traité
par là l'homme s'est notamment toute la
question des informations dont dispose
le travailleur en amont de la
proposition de course ou de la
proposition de livraison maintenant et
grâce en partie à la loi mais nous
sommes aussi allés au delà d'un slalom
livreurs et chauffeurs ont toutes les
informations nécessaires pour acceptées
et refusées quand je lis informations
c'est nécessaire c'est le prix de la
course c'est la destination et c'est la
durée de cette course sans que je le
répète
un refus de ces courses n'entraîne une
quelconque désactivation comme on a pu
l'entendre puisque la l'homme à nouveau
rappel que les plateformes doivent
assurer et confirmer qu'il n'y aura
aucune sanction pour ces travailleurs
lorsqu'ils refusent des propositions sur
ce point deuxième élément que je
voudrais noter c'est sur le fait que
nous continuons on entend parfaitement
la problématique du prix comme une
revendication qui revient de manière
récurrente
nous avons régulièrement des
concertations avec les représentants des
chauffeurs et les chauffeurs en direct
alors aujourd'hui ce ne seront pas des
représentants au sens de demain comme
nous les aurons dans lé dialogue social
mais en tout cas un certain nombre
d'associations qui se sont formés aussi
bien côté chauffeur que côté livreurs et
lorsqu'il ya des évolutions de grille
tarifaire
nous en discutons avec eux et nous
échangeons sur ces sujets ce qui a pu
donner lieu à des modulations de grille
tarifaire dans certaines villes et le
dernier point c'est pour vous donner un
exemple assez concret de ce que peut
donner le salariat lorsqu'on applique au
monde des plateformes nous avons dans le
canton de genève en suisse et est
condamné à ce que
livreur soient salariés n'ont pas de la
plate forme mais soit salarié de d'une
société et donc nous avons été obligés
de n'utiliser sur la plateforme que des
salariés de sociétés de gestion de
flotte
quelles ont été les conséquences
immédiates 75% des livreurs qui utiliser
notre application à genève n'ont plus
accès à l'application puisqu'ils n'ont
pas été recrutés par ces sociétés de
gestion de flottes et les 25% restants
sont bien évidemment devenu salarié et
ont continué à exercer leurs activités
avec les contraintes du salariat qu'il
ne souhaitait pas donc pour avoir un
exemple concret de ce que ça peut donner
peut-être lorraine je peux parler de
continuer sur la formation
oui alors peut-être y avait aussi un
élément sur la question du management
algorithmique et je pense que c'est un
élément essentiel qu'est ce que c'est
le management algorithmics est quand un
travailleur et monitorer dans son
activité quand son avis à lui s à sa
performance est évaluée et quand son
sont ses interactions avec le système ne
ne passe pas par un humain ou encore
quand il n'ya pas de transparence sur la
façon dont fonctionne cette
algorithmique
alors je pense qu'il faut être assez
honnête ici peut être
auparavant cette transparence n'existait
pas mais je voulais vous indiquer à un
certain nombre d'évolutions très
concrète qui a eu lieu ces dernières
années
d'une part la loi le maire qui oblige
les plateformes mais bas que a
communiqué sur leur site internet de
manière transparente le fonctionnement
dates de leurs algorithmes et c c'est le
cas au delà de ça uber a publié des
articles pédagogiques à destination des
travailleurs sur le fonctionnement de
son algorithme de quoi parle-t-on ici
c'est notamment cet algorithme en fait
qui est le coeur de notre technologie
qui va distribuer des propositions de
course à des chauffeurs et des livreurs
et donc ici nous avons expliqué
concrètement quels étaient les critères
pour que ses propositions soient faites
sur la question donc ça c'est sur la
question de la transparence sur la
question de l'interaction avec le
système
nous avons amélioré ses éléments pour
que chaque chauffeur chaque livreur
puisse parler à une personne chez nous
quand il a des problèmes avec
l'application des problèmes dans son
activité
la question de l'évaluation la question
de cette fameuse notation évidemment
c'est important pour nous puisque on a
besoin de garantir une certaine qualité
de service pour pour les clients finaux
mais en aucun cas je le répète cette
notation
elle intervient dans le choix dans la
dans les critères de distribution d'une
course et je veux rappeler aussi que
finalement est ce que la question ce
n'est pas tant cette question de la
technologie plutôt que de la question de
la prévisibilité la question de la
transparence pour le chauffeur et pour
le livreur sur les raisons qui peuvent
amener à une désactivation ou à une
suspension et je pense que c'est
vraiment là dessus que les plateformes
doivent travailler
nous avons commencé comme je le disais
en révisant nos procédures pour qu'un
chauffeur un livreur soit notifiée
plusieurs jours à l'avant ce compte on
voit qu'il y a un comportement quand il
ya des actions qui nous paraissent
difficilement compatible avec les
engagements des deux parties dans notre
contrat commercial
il ya une information de raison et aussi
des informations sur les procédures de
de contradictoire finalement et nous
avons mis en place des revues des cas
qui posent problème nous avons mis en
place un comité d'appel au sein de
l'activité de chauffeur vtc ce comité
d'appel est constitué de perd donc deux
chauffeurs qui vont être en mesure de
réévaluer ou de revoir le cas d'un
chauffeur qui aurait été désactivé et de
donner leur avis sur sur ce dossier là
encore je dois aussi mentionné que la
réglementation est passée par là puisque
vous avez un règlement européen qui a
été en mise en oeuvre l'été dernier en
france qui s'appelle plateforme tout
business et qui demande à ce que les
plateformes et donc pas que les plates
formes d'intermédiation comme les nôtres
mais par exemple aussi amazon donne les
raisons exactes par exemple du
déférencement la désactivation d'un
travailleur et propose aussi des
procédures de médiation et je pense
qu'il faut vraiment insister là dessus
sur cette question de prévisibilité et
de transparence pour les travailleurs
merci madame chagny peut-être sur
l'aspect social et juridique en quelques
mots d'après un ami qu le rapporteur
merci beaucoup c'est président je
voulais effectivement reprendre le fil
sur l'autonomie à l'indépendance revient
avec la question posée par rapporteur
regain en fait c'est sympa que j'ai
rapporté via d'évoquer le mot clé c'est
quand même le prix la meilleure garantie
pour un indépendant
d'être indépendant c'est d'être émancipé
économiquement et donc d'être en
capacité d'avoir un prix suffisant pour
de sa prestation de service et ça c'est
un point qui avait parfaitement enfin
saisi j'en ai froid dans leur rapport et
qu'on retrouve complètement dans le
rapport c'est à dire que c'est pas le
statut et la simulation au salariat qui
garantit le fait qu'on dégage un revenu
décent de son activité un salarié un
indépendant qui est rattachée à tout cas
qui est affiliée de qu'il ya si les
salariés comme le proposait le rapport
froid à une coopérative d'activités et
d'emploi ou portage salarial doit
dégager ses revenus lui permettant de
financer sa propre protection sociale et
c'est pour ça que j'en ai froid le rap
en francs avait pout avait poussé le
raisonnement jusqu'au bout en dix ans
mais en fait il faut aussi permettre
d'avoir quelques dispositions
impératives et donc ils avaient prévu
une rémunération minimum et dans le
dialogue social et prévoyait
effectivement de négocier au dessus de
cette rémunération mais c'était quand
même considérer est un mec qui dit que
c'est pas parce que vous êtes assis ni
les salariés et donc vous avez un statut
de salarié que vous êtes en capacité de
faire valoir suffisamment de rapport de
force pour dégager des revenus
d'activité suffisant et d'ailleurs c'est
là le c'est là un des points 2 2 fois 10
ans us que nous on a dans notre analyse
des propositions du rapport france était
qu'en gros il y avait l'idée dans le
rapport de dire en quelque sorte on va
créer des rapports de force
on va donc via la fédération des
coopératives d'activités et d'emploi ou
via le médecin pour le portage créer une
masse suffisante pour être en capacité
de négocier et donc aussi d'amener un
partage de la valeur
on n'a pas encore abordé entre la
plateforme dont qui acceptera une baisse
de la commission
peut-être le consommateur qui
accepteraient pourquoi pas patrick g
team a raté moment on envisagerait la
possibilité que le consommateur aussi
acceptent de payer un prix un petit peu
plus élevée pour certains pour certaines
prestations et puis le travailleur qui
doit effectivement
bénéficier d'une rémunération minimum et
les frais de gestion de 2,2 du tiers
sécurisé at her de fait le rapport a pas
été jusqu'au bout mais ça amène
réellement le fait qu'on est là dans un
an dans deux vins dans un contexte où se
pose la question du partage de la valeur
pour qu'effectivement un travailleur
puisse dégager des revenus d'activité
suffisant ce qui passe nécessairement
par la case d'un prix décent ça m'amène
à l'objet du financement de la
protection sociale et en particulier à
un débat important don pour n'a pas
enfin fait état de manière très je
dirais public dans le contexte de la
task force qui est le fait que
initialement faisait partie des objets
de dialogue social tel que proposé
pendant leur apportant la protection
sociale complémentaire
or il se trouve qu'en fait les
collectifs que vous connais bien se sont
battus pour que ce point là et
collectifs de travailleurs de
plateformes la plateforme pardon oui se
sont battus pour mathias est très bien
placé pour savoir pour retirer cette
dimension là des objets de dialogue et
pourquoi l'ont-ils fait non pas parce
qu'ils renonçaient et parce que leurs
dauphins comment dire il renonce à une
protection sociale et que c'est ça leur
désir bon moment ils l'ont fait parce
qu'en fait il considère que pour eux un
indépendant c'est quelqu'un qui est en
capacité de financiers sa propre
protection sociale et donc de dégager un
revenu d'activité qui lui permet de
financer aussi sa protection ça
n'exonère pas de penser qu'on a
effectivement une feinte au monde hier à
une discrimination discrimination au
regard des allègements de cotisations
sociales patronales en train indépendant
et un salarié pour un smicard que c'est
vrai que moi j'entends parfaitement
l'art du mot qui consiste à dire moi je
suis indépendant j'ai un niveau à peu
près de brut ou au niveau du smic moi je
ne bénéficie d'aucun allégement et toute
la protection je dois le financier moi
même et j'en terminerai par un dernier
point attend juste sur ce point l'idée
c'était de ne pas ajouter à une
d'immenses dépendance économique une
dépendance sociale qui serait lié au
fait que la protection sociale soit
dépendante de la plateforme et jean
ternie par un dernier point qui est
l' annexe iv du rapport de jean et
fraude ou de la page 123 qui donne un
certain nombre de critères permettant de
définir le travail indépendant
il se trouve que le prix n'est pas dans
ces critères-là et pour une raison
simple c'est qu'en fait il ya quelque
chose qui est extrêmement puissants dans
le rapport de jean et france et qu'il
est totalement cohérent il mais qu'en
fait c'est une sorte de mikado dans
lesquels quand vous enlevez un élément
du mikado il ya beaucoup d'autres enfin
dimension du pas de qui qui sont
affectés hors pourquoi ne le titre
n'as-tu pas fait c'est parce que la
question de la rémunération est donc de
socle minimum de rémunération elle est
fixée ailleurs par des dispositions
impératives dans le rapport donc si on
n'a pas en tête le fait qu' il à la
définition qui est proposée dans le
rapport dans l' annexe iv est
complètement fin corrélés est imbriqué
dans toutes les autres propositions et y
compris dans le fait de mettre en place
des dispositifs permettant aux
travailleurs de dégager des revenus
décents
on passe à côté de ce qui ce qui est
dedans ce que l'annexé iv propose comme
la définition d'un travailleur du
travail indépendant merci madame chagny
alors on va faire un point d'étape
il reste deux rapporteurs je vais passer
par le site à michel canevet des
réponses rapides de de nos intervenants
et puis ensuite jean luc fichet pour la
commission de faire les séries
merci monsieur le président merci à nos
intervenants je vais faire très court
dans ce cas on est dans un secteur qui
vont dans le sens de considérer qu'il
est innovante et l'innovation est
intéressante parce que je suscite
beaucoup d'interrogations
alors on voit bien qu'ici bas plusieurs
problèmes se posent pour nous
législateurs il ya bien sûr la question
du droit de la concurrence qui doit être
regardé parce qu'il s'agit pas de faire
en sorte que les situations deviennent
inéquitable donc il est important que
l'on regarde ce sujet là et puis le
droit de du travail cela a été largement
évoqué tout à l'heure parce qu'on a
aussi le souci de la protection sociale
de l'ensemble des
de nos concitoyens donc c'est quelque
chose d'important puis il ya des sujets
d'autres sujets qui reviennent et je
voulais demander à madame jeannine
notamment sur les questions de
management d'algorithmique donc on a
parlé d'autres a parlé tout à l'heure
quels étaient les impératifs qu'elle
voyait à à prendre en compte
effectivement et puis pour hubert je
voulais demander si les deux activités
de mobilité donc d'une part le vtc et
d'autre part l'activité de course si
pour eux c'est vraiment le même type
d'activité parce que on comprend que
pour le vtc l'activité de la dépendance
soit plutôt privilégier d'ailleurs les
taxis fonctionne de façon indépendante
ce sont les principaux concurrents par
contre pour ce qui concerne la livraison
de repas
on l'a dit tout à l'heure ça a été dit
monsieur dufour l'a évoqué largement
aussi il ya une relation quand même ce
sont des services l'intermédiation est
l'accessoire ce sont surtout des
services de transport de marchandises
totalement finalement le travail on a un
peu que peu de choix même si certains
opérateurs comme hubert en mis en place
différents dispositifs mais il ya quand
même un lien de subordination qui est
extrêmement fort et certains opérateurs
comme juste it france par exemple salary
donc ça veut dire c'est possible de le
faire à l'afflux de demandes et hubert
pourquoi si il n'y a pas de différence
qu'on re entre les deux types
d'activités qu'il réalise
merci donc on va dans dans l'ordre des
questions de notre à porter madame
chagny peut-être avec monsieur du show
bien sûr résille
sur la question du management
algorithmique le propos que je vais
porter tout à l'heure était aussi de
dire qu'il ya enfin c'est quelque chose
qu'il faut comprendre comme allant bien
au delà des seuls travers de plateformes
et donc la réflexion que nous on perd on
porte c'est l'idée de dire qu'en gros il
faut enfin un petit peu aussi
démystifier l'idée de l'algorithme
patron et qu'il faut aussi apporter des
réponses à tous les acteurs et qu'en
fait en gros il s'agit enfin aux acteurs
aussi bien des travailleurs de
plateformes que des acteurs en
entreprise
donc si c'était ça le sens de mon
intervention donc je vais tout petit peu
développée là dessus et en fait et en
plus en gros de ceux déjà d'identifier
mais comme lauren gardiola avait tout à
fait préciser de quoi on parle parce que
c'est vrai que effectivement on a
souvent un petit peu une difficulté à
définir exactement ce qu'on entend par
un algorithme qui est un autre attrait
général et de fait enfin le la
planification des personnes en fonction
des besoins l'évaluation par notation
s'adapte des années 90 donc ça date pas
d'aujourd'hui
nous ce qu'on se comporte c'est l'idée
de dire qu'il faut en fait que en gros
il ya une control soultz de l'outil qui
parce que son temps des deux côtés du
côté de sylvie qui en passent commande
et du comme du côté de celui qui va y
être assujettis du côté de l'exécutant
notre notre vin se comporte c'est l'idée
de dire qu'en gros il faut donner aux
travailleurs les moyens de comprendre et
les algorithmes et d'agir en
connaissance de cause et
qu'effectivement il faut bien qu'on
fasse en sorte que les droits qui sont
garantis parure gpd et patronne to
business qui a été évoqué ne restent pas
purement théorique et qu'il faut donc en
garantir et renforcer l'accessibilité
pour les travailleurs en gros c'est
aller vers davantage de transparence de
lisibilité et d'évolution enfin parlons
de de capacité dans le dialogue social
qui est exact exactement de propositions
du rapport frouard et qui a été repris
dans le cas de la taxe forces de m au
coeur du dialogue social la transparence
et la lisibilité et l'évolution des
algorithmes
et alors juste un point quand même à
rappeler c'est qu'en fait en gros à
l'heure actuelle il faut pas oublier que
le représentant du personnel ont un
droit de consultation prévue dans les
situations de l'introduction de
nouvelles technologies saint pois qu'on
a un petit peu tendance à mettre de côté
mais par contre et c'est ça qui est très
intéressant quand on regarde ce qui se
passe et les réflexions qui se mène à
l'échelle internationale dans le monde
syndical on va dire c'est qu'en fait on
se rend compte que les représentants du
personnel sont très rarement consultées
sur ces sujets et que par ailleurs il
mobilise très rarement la possibilité
d'être consultés sur le sujet par eux
mêmes au pied y compris un élément de
enfin d'appropriation par les
représentants du personnel de ce sujet
donc s'agissant des travers de
plateformes effectivement le rapport
froid proposer un certain nombre de
commandes hier de proposition et nous
notre notre réflexion allait aussi de
dire qu'il faut accompagner donc là je
viens dans le monde de l'entreprise soit
aussi accompagner les managers et les
directions y compris face simplement
pour faire mettre un acteur aux acteurs
en entreprises d'exercer un contrôle des
algorithmes qu'ils utilisent ce qu'il
n'est pas du tout assurée et qu'il faut
aussi gérer et accompagner la
redéfinition des processus de prise de
décision au sein de l'entreprise
notamment pauvres aussi parce qu'il ya
on a là un risque avéré de
désincarnation la responsabilité des
managers et qu'en fait il ya vraiment un
gros gros sujet est en jeu
d'accompagnement des acteurs et alors
ils accompagnement des acteurs pour le
coup il avait été clairement identifiés
par la ppl déposée par certaines sur le
recours à l'expert puisqu'il y avait
effectivement l'idée d'aller chercher
l'expertisé mais c'est ce sujet est
absolument essentiel merci alors avant
de passer avant de passer la parole je
vais demander à monsieur fichiers de
poser ces questions parce qu'il ya un
impératif et également des déplacements
voilà merci merci et monsieur le
président en effectuant je dois vous
quitter à 11 heures parce que j'ai un
train aussitôt après et donc d'abord
merci de votre invitation pour réfléchir
sur un sujet qui est à mon avis tout à
fait à ses débuts
je crois qu'on aura vraiment à
travailler au fond sur ces sur ces
questions puisque on est sur de
nouvelles pratiques
on est sur une nouvelle forme de travail
créé la notion de plateformes et des
chapeaux grand nombre de nos citoyens
aujourd'hui pourtant on voit bien
comment elle
elles deviennent de plus en plus
présente et comment ils vont
réinterroger au fond notre législation
notre rapport au travail et tout lé
statut de travailleur et d'indépendants
autonome qui sait
moi je pense que il ya quand même une
chose qu'il ne faut pas négliger dans
ces affaires là certains des arguments
qui est tenu par hubert qui était qu'il
faut entendre c'est de dire mais il ya
75 % des travailleurs qui ne souhaitent
pas afin d'aider indépendante qui ne
souhaite pas devenir salarié celle que
le statut leur suffit est bon et je
pense que ça nécessite quand même d'être
creusée au fond c'est cette question sur
capacité à répondre s'ils venaient de
salariés ou indépendants compte tenu de
la situation de grande précarité dans
laquelle ils sont tous c'est que ce sont
des étudiants ce sont des gens qui n'ont
pas de formation en fin et que la durée
aujourd'hui c'est mes informations sont
bonnes d'un contrat n'excède pas 1 an et
n'excède pas 1 an parce que quand on
crée la situation d'auto entrepreneur à
l'auto entreprise
on bénéficie de la cre de ned vous
s'ajoutent aux nouvelles entreprises et
qui qui se dilue sur trois années mais
la première année est importante et donc
du coup elle crée un revenu qui est
intéressant la deuxième année c'est
moins intéressant troisième année ça
l'est plus du tout et donc on voit
aujourd'hui que passé il n'y a pas de
contrat qui n'excède un an donc là aussi
à mon avis il ya quand même une question
sur le niveau de rémunération sur le
statut et sur la manière dont ça ça va
fonctionner pour essayer d'organiser une
visibilité de l'emploi une visibilité
dans la durée
et puis comment on va sortir un petit
peu de ce jeu sub style subtil parce que
la plateforme d'intermédiation festayres
qu' on est dans quelque chose qu'ils
essaient de la dentelle soul matière
juridique terre que chacun c'est
précisément quels mots il utilise dire
que ont fait de l'information ont fait
de la rencontre mais on n'a aucune
structure de représentativité qui est
véritablement existantes
on n'a pas de partenaire ya pas deux et
ça ça ne peut durer qu'un temps ça ne va
pas à mon avis ça ne peut pas se
poursuivre dans un esprit aussi
aujourd'hui parce que il ya quand même
un grand souci c'est la protection des
indépendants des livreurs partenaires
parce que il faut aussi différencier ce
qui est du vtc des chauffeurs qui
aujourd'hui ont déjà beaucoup évolué
dans leurs statuts dire que les
chauffeurs sont indépendants mais ils
ont des véhicules qui devait être normé
ils ont une licence
ils ont une formation ils ont une
visibilité de travail qui n'est pas
encore celle des des livreurs
partenaires donc il faut bien les
différencier
et regardez un peu comment plus
spécifiquement prêt des livres
partenaires on va pouvoir travailler à
ce qu' il ait une vraie un vrai statut
une vraie visibilité en terme d'emploi
et puis un niveau de rénumération qu'ils
soient correctes alors il ya il ya et ça
mon avis ça va c'est quand même le point
un peu centrale de d'affaires c'est
qu'ils aient à nouveau je sais pas ce
voit plus un partenaire mais qui est
totalement non identifiables c'est
l'algorithme ce que c'est magique
l'algorithme dire que ça donne une masse
d'informations
ça a évolué quasiment ça génère ses
propres ses propres critères ses propres
évolutions et on sait pas si cet
algorithme la key qui le commandent
réellement quelques quel impact il va
avoir à maurice dans la durée est-ce que
ça génère de la subordination pape tube
ordination est-ce que voilà donc c'est
un petit peu toutes ces questions que je
me pose mais je crois quand même qu'il
faut je sais pas si ça a été fait mais
je crois qu 6 regardez quand même de qui
on parle
celle qu'on parle d'eux
qui sont dans une grande précarité et
leur capacité à répondre objectivement
aux questions qui leur sont posées et je
ne suis pas sûr qu'elle soit vraiment
objective parce que ils sont extrêmement
dépendants de ce travail là pour une
durée courte mais c'est très important
pour eux est ce que c'est de la question
alimentaire presque de la survie merci
alors donc de ce plan pratique du
fonctionnement
il échangera les hits même s'affrontent
sur wii pour pourrait pour distinguer en
effet je pense que c'est important de le
faire les deux les deux activités mais
aussi pour noter qu'en réalité j'ai
l'impression qu'on s'accordent tous à
dire qu'il ya une vraie différence entre
le chauffeur vtc et le livreur pourtant
la jurisprudence à requalifier un
chauffeur en tout cas pour ce qui nous
concerne et n'a pas al'inverse qualifié
de deux livreurs utilisant l'application
humeur ritz et vous l'indiquez monsieur
mais la jurisprudence ne confirme pas
qu'il existe un lien de subordination
avec notre plateforme mais aussi avec
d'autres ya un vrai absente arrêt la
cour d'appel de paris sur sur des lits
verrous et c'est et votre comparaison
avec joystick mérite de s'attarder en
effet sur un point c'est que lorsqu'on
parle des plateformes
il faut systématiquement vérifier les
conditions réelles dans lesquelles les
livreurs ou les chauffeurs vont exercer
leur activité et le modèle de chaque
plateforme est très différent vous avez
des plateformes qui impose des shifts
donc vraiment dé préinscription sur des
créneaux horaires avec donc une
organisation est potentiellement une
perte d'accès à d'autres créneaux
horaires si vous n'avez pas honoré le
créneau sur lequel vous étaient inscrits
etc
il est évident que lorsqu'on est dans
une organisation à un contrôle comme
celui ci on se rapproche très fortement
du salariat pour hubert ritz et du
beurre on
absolument pas dans ces logiques là et
donc notre modèle est très différent de
celui de joystiq puisque nous ce que
vous nous continuons à vouloir offrir
aux chauffeurs et aux livreurs c'est
cette flexibilité totale c'est à dire
que sans nous informer et après chaque
course
le livre et le chauffeur peuvent soit
jongler avec une autre application avec
leur clientèle personnelle ou tout
simplement décidé de ne plus utiliser
nos applications pendant des semaines
voire des mois
et puis la retrouver lorsqu'ils en
auront besoin
un autre point sur les livreurs nous
n'avons jamais caché le fait que la
livraison à domicile contrairement au
monde du vtc n'est pas une activité qui
structurellement peut-être une activité
réalisée à temps plein pourquoi parce
que de fait elle est saisonnière et
pendulaires saisonnière parce que alors
je mets entre parenthèses la période
qu'ovide mais saisonnière parce que tout
simplement on commande - à domicile en
été qu'en hiver et pendulaires parce que
vous avez en france la culture du
déjeuner et du dîner et donc l'activité
s'organise véritablement à ces moments
là et c'est pour ça qu'elle s'adresse
aussi à des personnes qui veulent en
faire une utilisation temporaire
exclusivement et donc cesser c'est
justement parce que nous avons ces
profils différents ces conditions
d'activités différentes qui semble
indispensable d'avoir une clarté sur ce
qu'est et n'est pas un indépendant et
tant qu'on n'aura pas tranché un peu
plus précisément que le fait la
jurisprudence le lien de subordination
on demeurera présomption de salariat ou
pas dans cette incertitude juridique et
je faisais référence à la décision
lionel précédemment non pas pour
indiquer qu'elle avait requalifié est
confirmée l'indépendance mais pour
l'utiliser comme une référence dans les
critères et la frontière indépendants
salariés et elle nous en donne trois qui
sont particulièrement intéressants le
premier c'est la possibilité de refuser
les missions qu'on vous propose
ou d'en fixer un seuil
minimum le deuxième c'est d'avoir une
totale organisation dans ses horaires de
travail et le troisième c'est d'avoir la
capacité à travailler pour des tiers
voire des tiers concurrents à une
plateforme où la l'entreprenant
l'employeur a légué parce que lorsqu'on
à ces trois critères on ne parle pas de
l'autonomie du travailleur salarié
cadres dirigeants ou cadres au forfait
jours c'est pas du tout de cette à
autonomie là dont on parle puisque cet
automne ovni dans tous les cas en sous
jacent
on a une obligation de rendre compte
l'ajustement dans les critères tels
qu'ils sont définis au niveau européen
dans la décision et you d'elle c'est
véritablement une première frontière
qu'on pourrait utiliser à nouveau pour
permettre de classer peut-être certains
modèles de plates formes dans des cases
et dans l'autre merci alors on il nous
reste 10 minutes donc je vais donner la
parole à madame gomes et elle est
toujours en ligne pour cet aspect social
et d'indépendance et puis ensuite
monsieur dufour qui vous l'a demandé et
quelques mots peut-être de monsieur
chacun qui est donc l'auteur de la
proposition de loi
en conclusion ultime de nos échanges
donc madame l'hommage à luzy peut-être
une précision sur la façon dont les
juges ont parlé requalification il dit
juge s'intéresse en droit français est
désormais d'ailleurs aussi de plus en
plus en droit britannique s'intéresse à
aux conditions réelles d'exécution
d'activité donc en dépit de ce que dit
le contrat en dépit par exemple des
possibilités qui peuvent être laissés au
livreur d'avoir plusieurs employeurs
d'organiser leur temps de travail camila
soit etc
même si ces possibilités sont
formalisées ce qui va intéresser le
juger comment en réalité la pratique se
dérouler ce qu'en réalité ces personnes
ont une véritable capacité
choisir l'organisation du travail la
façon dont ils veulent fonctionner etc
il s'avère qu'en pratique et c'est le
cas de la majorité des travers des
plateformes
il y a peu de travailleurs qui vole une
plateforme à l'autre que ce sont des
professions en tout cas pour les
chauffeurs et les livreurs qui se
professionnalise la plus en plus et où
les heures de travail sont extrêmement
élevées elles sont élevées notamment
parce que les rémunérations sont si
faibles que les personnes obligées de
beaucoup beaucoup travailler pour
pouvoir avoir un minimum de rémunération
et c'est pas déjà ici tout de suite mais
la dégradation des conditions de travail
qu'on a observés sur des plateformes
elles ont eu pour conséquence une
extrême paupérisation je le disais tout
à l'heure des travailleurs qui
travaillent pour elles ce qui fait que
évidemment plus on est près car et plus
on va devoir on accepte de travail des
conditions extrêmement difficiles et
plus on doit multiplier les heures pour
des revenus extrêmement extrêmement
faible donc c'est évidemment il y aura
tous il ya toujours eu ce pas que pour
les plateformes des divergences parfois
entre les juges du fond la cour de
cassation je le rappelle est là pour
dire le droit elle a dit le droit et en
ce sens ça il n'y a pas la moindre
ambiguïté juridiquement sur la
qualification de ces travailleurs il
s'agit d'un choix
la politique est ce qu on veut maintenir
les travailleurs dans ce statut salarial
ou alors est-ce qu'on veut légitimer la
volonté des plateformes de faire plier
le les normes des états à leur stratégie
managériale c'est un choix mais c'est le
choix ce qui qui qui est ce qu'ils se
posent
mais en tout cas juridiquement il n'y a
pas d'ambiguïté là dessus que ce soit en
france comme au royaume uni par ailleurs
désormais sur l'algorithme juste une
précision
l'algorithme ce n'est pas autre chose
que la traduction en langage
informatique de voir patronales en
l'occurrence pour l'orienter
l'organisation du travail
l'algorithme us est pensé et construit
par quelqu'un est donc quand il sert à
organiser une
une activité sélectivement la traduction
de directives de contrôle de sanctions
qui vont être du coup automatisés en
langage informatique donc évidemment on
peut à craindre qu' il n'y ait pas de
contrôle sur ses algorithmes et
évidemment que les plateformes au
contraire l on est toutes les
entreprises parce que aux déchets ni le
disais tout à l'heure il n'y a pas que
les plateformes qui utilise des
algorithmes pour encadrer les activités
des travailleurs à partir du moment où
on va utiliser l'algorithme on a tout
intérêt à avoir le contrôle de ces abris
pour savoir exactement comment comment
s'organise le travail donc il n'a pas le
contrôle se réalise sur la façon dont on
va organiser le travail informatiquement
parlant donc la très peu en réalité de
risque de quatre départs de contrôle en
réalité puisque c'est le nerf sedona
bélingard pour pour les patients mais
pour toutes les entreprises car des
jugements de contrôle de son activité
donc évidemment aidé tout ça est
extrêmement limitée et à ce titre jamais
rappelé auditionné daddy l'un des leurs
qui est l'introduction aux
technologiques dans une entreprise les
représentants du personnel ont une
compétence pour justement avoir donné
leur avis être informé et consulté sur
ces introductions là mais de manière
plus générale on pourrait imaginer qu'à
partir du moment où des algorithmes
peuvent être utiles nécessaires à
l'organisation de l'entreprise
ces algorithmes serait l'incompétence du
cso et donc s'ils sont la compétence du
cso on voit encore plus l'intérêt qu'il
y aurait à reconnaître la qualité de
salarié au travers des plateformes
puisque toutes les questions que l'on se
pose actuellement la protection sociale
l'organisation collective d'année mandat
aussi syndicaux pour organiser ce
dialogue et et avoir des représentants
du personnel avec qui discuter la
transparence des algorithmes ayant tout
ça est résolu par le statut salarial
le cso notamment est une réponse pour
réfléchir à la transparence des
algorithmes savoir comment fonctionnent
ces algorithmes et comment ils ont une
influence sur l'organisation du travail
sur les rémunérations etc
et en plus on sait que les représentants
du personnel dans le cas du 16e peuvent
aussi avoir des idées
obligation de confidentialité quand les
algorithmes peuvent effectivement relevé
de l'or du secret professionnel et c'est
donc tout est déjà très bien organisés
et je pense que ce qui serait
intéressant c'est justement de regarder
ce qui existe en est d'adapter
éventuellement à la pratique mais
d'éviter peut-être de reconstruire du
droit du travail et du droit social de
manière générale sans avoir à côté les
droits opposables qui vont permettre
l'efficacité et la sécurité de 2,7 de
cette législation est peut-être une
dernière chose les pas de peindre comme
toute entreprise
elle pense elle développe elle organise
une activité et je pense qu'à ce titre
il serait normal que il y aussi des des
droits qui leur soit opposable savent
qu'elle soit responsable
elle tire profit d'une activité elles
doivent être responsables aussi de cette
activité là et donc participer
contribuer dans cas des cotisations
sociales etc stamm et mais contribue
justement à aa être responsabilisés
est-ce que l'offre imputable pour le
coup certaines responsabilités
juridiques
merci alors monsieur dufour
oui je voulais réagir par rapport au
débat sur les travers des plateformes de
jeu le veulent être indépendants ou ne
veulent pas être salarié moi je suis pas
tout à fait à l'aise parce qu'on parle
en leur nom
alors certes y'a des sondages etc mais
j'ai envie de dire chiche
si ici on pense qu'ils veulent pas être
salarié bas donnons leur la possibilité
puis on verra bien ce qu'il choisisse et
ça ça peut être quelque chose de très
concret de dire sur les plateformes vous
avez le choix soit vous êtes indépendant
soit vous êtes salarié et on laisse les
gens choisir et puis on verra bien voilà
et ça peut permettre de sortir des
débats entre la requalification en
versus le statu quo on a les deux qui
sont ouverts au lieu de les opposer
c'est l'un ou l'autre voie et on verra
bien ce qui se passe
[Musique]